hey David what would a gun-control
compromise look like between left and
right okay
let's do this but we have to agree on a
parameter first because otherwise we're
not going to get anywhere
given that the second amendment exists
what would a compromise look like if we
are really going to imagine a compromise
that ignores that the second amendment
exists even if you don't like the second
amendment even if you wish the second
amendment didn't exist we won't get
anywhere in imagining a compromise that
assumes the second amendment doesn't
exist so we actually have to account for
that when we think about what a gun
safety compromise might look like
between left and right but I actually
think there's a bigger problem that we
have to talk about we could rattle off
policies I could say well the right
could concede universal background
checks and maybe we would ban some
high-capacity magazines and the left
would have to concede something else
then we would just argue about whether
that's too far left or too far right or
too extreme we would get nowhere in
reality though because there's a bigger
issue when you talk about a gun safety
compromise the problem here is not a
practical problem we could get together
and workshop ideas and come to some kind
of hypothetical compromise where both
sides would give some stuff up and get
something and everybody would be sort of
unhappy which is often the way a good
compromise ends up the problem is we
can't actually have that conversation in
good faith because number one everyone
will see the compromise as a Trojan
horse and then immediately imagine that
the other side is going to just try to
get more and use the compromise as a way
to move the needle slightly and number
two you have very well-funded market
altering players like the NRA that are a
direct impediment to actually having
good-faith conversations about this
stuff so it's actually a completely
intractable conversation the causes of
gun violence need to be addressed the
availability of guns needs to be
addressed mental health sure needs to be
addressed gun culture the religion of
guns is a massive problem in the United
States and for good reason no one trusts
the other side to negotiate in good
faith I'm not doing both sides
ISM okay the pro-gun more guns and more
places side is disgusting and they are
extremely well-funded by these gun
manufacturers through groups like the
NRA but whatever list you and I can come
up with right now about what a
compromise would look like is
effectively dead on arrival because
groups like the NRA are very good at
getting even Donald Trump to say oh I
was for background checks yeah we're not
doing that anymore and number two if you
concede anything the other side will say
that's not in good faith you're just
doing this in order to in six months
push for more and we're not going to
allow it and this is unfortunately one
of the areas in which I am most
pessimistic gun safety I've talked
already about climate change if you've
been watching the show you know that I'm
not particularly optimistic on the
climate gun safety is another area where
I am not at all optimistic that we are
going to make it happen and a huge
reason for that is the just corrosive
and disgusting
effect of organizations like the NRA and
I I want to be convinced that this could
happen I really do but look at what
happened with background checks after
Sandy Hook look at all of the other
examples so I am not particularly
optimistic and I think whatever list we
could come up with would be taking an
immediate backseat to the partisan and
lobbied in moneyed lobbying interests
that exist within gun safety let me know
if I'm wrong and I should have some more
optimism on this we've got a great bonus
show coming up for you today become a
member or a patron to get instant access
at join pakman.com or patreon.com slash
david pakman show